Cory it's great to see you man last I
can sense the humility just oozing out
of you now since you've joined
Congress I I can feel it in you man like
what that must be last time you were
here you weren't in Congress you were
running I'm pretty sure you that was you
were campaigning while and now it's just
like you're like it's like I can it's
like you've like matured in a way but I
can only imagine what what the last year
has been like well I'll tell you I've
been really lucky like while I've been
in Congress I got put on some really
amazing committees I mean I'm on the
armed services committee I'm on the
Foreign Affairs committee I'm on the the
intelligent Special Operations
subcommittee military personnel
subcommittee oversight accountability
subcommittees I mean it's been a good
time like we actually are being
effective through the experience and
Merit that you know we kind of built
through everything unlike where you see
most of the time when you go in there
it's you know who's kissed the ring and
you know how much money did you donate
and so you know there's the Congress is
certainly a broken institution but I
think that the 11 18th Congress kind of
the America First Patriots has come in
we're trying to do our best to to repair
that get back to constitutionality